- [Voiceover] The spring is
now compressed twice as much,
to delta x equals 2D.
A student is asked to predict
whether the final position
of the block will be twice
as far at x equals 6D.
The student reasons that since
the spring will be compressed
twice as much as before, the
block will have more energy
when it leaves the spring,
so it will slide farther
along the track before stopping
at position x equals 6D.
So, let's just think about
what the student is saying
or what's being proposed here.
So, in the first version, the
first scenario, we compressed
the block, we compressed the spring by D.
And then, the spring
accelerates the block.
And then, right when we
get back to x equals zero,
all of that potential
energy has been turned into
kinetic energy.
And then, the friction is acting
against the motion of the block,
so you can view it as it's
providing negative work.
The direction of the force is
opposite to the change in x.
And the negative work eventually
causes the block to stop.
And all of that kinetic energy
has now turned into heat.
And so, the block goes 3D.
Now, this new scenario, we
could call that scenario two,
we are going to compress
the spring twice as far.
So, now we're gonna compress
So, we're gonna compress it by 2D.
So, this is x equals negative 2D here.
And what's being said,
or what's being proposed,
by the student is alright, if
we compress it twice as far,
all of this potential
energy is then going to be,
we're definitely going to have
more potential energy here
because it takes more work to
compress the spring that far.
And then, all of that more
potential energy is gonna
be converted to more kinetic
energy once we get back
to x equals zero.
And so, not only will it go
further, but they're saying
it'll go exactly twice as far.
So, we are going to go,
instead of going to 3D, we are
now going to go to 6D.
Now, let's read.
Let's see what the questions are here.
And actually, I'm gonna put
a question mark here since
I'm not sure if that is exactly right.
So, part (b) i., let me do this.
So, we're in part (b) i.
It says which aspects of the
student's reasoning, if any,
are correct.
Explain how you arrived at your answer.
And then, part two says which
aspects of the student's
reasoning, if any, are incorrect.
Explain how you arrived at your answer.
So, the student is correct that two times,
so compressing more,
compressing spring more,
spring more, will result
in more energy when the
block leaves the spring,
result in more energy
when block leaves the spring,
block leaves spring,
which will result in the block
going further, which will result,
or the block going farther I should say,
which will result in
longer stopping distance,
which will result in longer stopping
stopping distance.
Now, part two.
Part two, here.
Which aspect of the
student's reasoning, if any,
are incorrect.
Explain how you arrive at your answer.
Well, two times I could
say, let me say compressing,
compressing twice as much,
twice as much, does not result
in exactly twice the stopping distance,
does not result in
twice the stopping distance,
the stopping distance.
And we can explain more if we like.
We know that potential
energy is equal to 1/2 times
the spring constant times how
much we compress, squared.
So, we could say that energy,
energy grows
with the square,
of compression of how much
we compress it.
of how much
we compress.
So, two times the compression.
I'm gonna say two times.
I'll write it out, two times compression
will result in four times
the energy.
Energy.
And this will result in four
times the stopping distance,
four times stopping distance,
four times stopping,
stopping, distance.
I think that it does a decent
job of explaining where
the student is correct, where
their reasoning is correct,
and where it is incorrect.